[Applauso]
diciamo che è abbastanza evidente che
non sono un ingegnere è abbastanza
evidente che non sono competente per
pensare una riqualificazione delle
periferie e che probabilmente alla gran
parte di voi non ho nulla di che
insegnare oggi però sono tante altre
cose come come diceva donatella faccio
altre cose e cerco sempre di farne tante
e nelle cose che faccio
c'è sempre un fil rouge credo di essere
un po una sognatrice ed è ed è il motivo
per cui quando da una tela mi ha
invitato questo tel
ho accettato ho pensato che ci potevo
provare anche se proprio il titolo non
era tra quelli che uno dice proprio
nelle mie corde
quindi oggi sono qui per portarvi
attraverso il mio sogno un sogno che mi
è sempre molto caro e portarvi ci si con
la testa ma soprattutto col cuore quindi
la mia città la città che è una
periferia oggi è una città che
rappresenta la società è una città
quindi che è invisibile una città che è
immaginaria una città che forse anche un
po ignota perché spesso non ci si ferma
a guardarla bene da una città complessa
dal punto di vista architettonico facile
dal punto di vista di barriere di
passaggi passaggi nascosti è una città
molto più complessa ora vorrei portarvi
con me in questa città perché credo che
sia l'unico modo in cui forse riesco a
farvi vedere quello che chi vedo io e
quindi vi direi che partiamo per partire
forse vi chiederei la cosa più facile no
cioè provare un attimo a staccarvi da
qua chiudere gli occhi fate fate come
volete io io cerco di portarvi da dove
io vedo la città e cerco di farvi vedere
quello che vedo io
immaginate di essere su una collina una
collina verde erba bellissima una
collina immensa tantissima gente
tantissima già in tema proprio
sterminata non c'è niente apparentemente
non c'è niente in realtà questa collina
sconfina e appena vi affacciate oltre
alla collina c'è una città
su questa collina c'è grandissimo caldo
un sole bellissimo effettivamente tutti
stanno diciamo così godendo di questo
bel tempo le persone vengono spinte e
vengono
diciamo spinte ad affacciarsi ea
guardare questa città dall'alto che cosa
vediamo che cosa vedete questa città è
una città storica una delle nostre
tantissime città potete pensare alla
città che vi è più cara quella che
conoscete meglio ed è una città tipica
nella sua costruzione no quindi abbiamo
un centro ampio ben curato pieno di
edifici molto belli le mura di questa
città e queste mura sono come sono le
mura delle nostre città alte molto
capace di proteggere molto solide e sono
intervallate da cosa dalle porte perché
come si entra nelle città se non per le
porte e quindi abbiamo le porte possiamo
contarli
una due tre porte tre porte d'ingresso
alla città
e queste porte come sono sono imponenti
sono grandi ma sono chiuse sono chiuse
vedremo che davanti a queste porte
abbiamo dei mostri che chiudono queste
porte poi fuori da queste mura che
racchiudono questo centro questo centro
maschile abbiamo le periferie che
passano dal centro singolare maschile ad
essere un plurale femminile e come sono
queste periferie sono meno ordinate sono
meno razionali sono più trash parmalat e
sono meno curate sono quello che sono le
nostre periferie di oggi i margini di
una società
il nostro centro che cos'è il centro
centro del potere il centro della
politica è il centro delle nostre
aziende sono gli amministratori delegati
sono i primari degli ospedali sono il
management delle aziende e poi abbiamo
le periferie dove ci sono tutte le
persone che lavorano che lavorano in
queste aziende che portano quelli che
fanno i grandi capi su come si dice
torniamo sulla nostra collina siamo
sulla nostra collina abbiamo detto fa
veramente caldo sole fortissimo si sente
sulla pelle
distribuiscono due cose sulla collina
per tutti i visitatori bottigliette
d'acqua a volontà e un cappellino avete
diritto tutti ad un cappellino potete
avere un cappellino rosso
se siete donne ragazze signore bambine o
un cappellino blu
se siete uomini ragazzi bambini ognuno
col proprio cappellino mese tutti i
cappellini ci viene chiesto di scendere
di scendere nella città di andare a
riempire la città questa città però non
vi ho detto che è un po magica e manca
di una cosa manca dei tetti tutti gli
edifici sono visibili dall'alto
ognuno di voi se posso rimane sulla
collina rimanete individualmente sulla
collina sedetevi nel punto dove vi
potete affacciare meglio e dove potete
vedere meglio scorgere meglio cosa
succede sotto
sedetevi comodi avete l'acqua vediamo
anche un binocolo e voi guardate che
cosa succede mentre questo fiume di
persone con i loro cappellini blu e
rossi ben mischiati scende scende dalla
collina e si riversa nella città scende
che è un chiacchiericcio un fiume
bellissimo colorato variopinto che
scende ed invade la città
lasciamoli invadere e sempre seduti
molto in comodi in cima sull'erbetta col
vostro binocolo provate a guardare sotto
cosa vedete vedete quello che vedo io
vedete un centro fatto di tantissime
teste blu pochissimi cappellini rossi si
fa fatica a contarli si fa fatica a
vederli nella mischia e poi vediamo
tutte queste periferie un po sfrangiate
un po meno ordinate con tantissimi
cappellini rossi tantissimi puntini
rossi sparsi mentre il centro blu è
molto concentrato e molto intenso e un
blu profondo e poi vediamo le porte
abbiamo detto che abbiamo tre porte e
cosa fanno queste porte sono abbiamo
detto ostruite da dei mostri
questi mostri sono gli stereotipi sono
dei mostri che proteggono il centro e
che ci fanno replicare modelli che
conosciamo e non permettono a chi non
corrisponde a quel modello di
oltrepassare la porta quindi proteggono
quello che già esistente e non lasciano
penetrare quello che viene considerato
diverso nuovo cos'è uno stereotipo
andando molto molto semplice e lo
stereotipo come come tipologia viene
dall'idea di essere uno stampo di
cartapesta in cui si mette il piombo
fuso per poter replicare la stessa cosa
ecco questo è immaginatevi è una cosa
che noi ci mettiamo nel cervello è
qualcosa che va e costringe il nostro
pensiero e come lo costringe il nostro
pensiero facendoci in modo intuitivo
pensare sempre le stesse cose e queste
cose sono cose che sono permeate sono
nella nostra pelle sono nella nostra
società sono nelle nostre case nelle
nostre scuole e sono cose che vengono in
automatico quindi abbiamo tantissimi
stereotipi gli stati sono legati al
gruppi di persone sono positivi sono
negativi ma il vero punto è che non sono
un pensiero libero ma sono un
condizionamento e la vera cosa che gli
stereotipi si dice che sono profezie che
si auto realizzano dicevamo che abbiamo
tra i mostri andiamo attraverso questi
tre macro punti di stereotipo queste tre
macro aree la prima porta grande
grandissima abbiamo i mostri mostri i
nomi li ha dati la mia figlia piccola
infatti il primo si chiama il mostro
sotto al letto ed è che stereotipo è
nello stereotipo di tutto quello che è
l'idea della cultura della famiglia è
questo mostro sotto il letto che quello
che i bambini coi bambini hanno paura
che un po stropicciato un po cosa cosa
fa
continua a lavorare su questa idea che
in casa
la mamma si occupa di tutti la mamma
gestisce le faccende domestiche
la mamma è quella che rinuncia se c'è
qualcuno che deve rifare al mondo del
lavoro
la mamma è quella che deve dedicarsi
prevalentemente i figli perché
diversamente viene giudicata dalla
società non sei mai
cioè di essere una brava mamma e e come
si lavora su questo ruote uno stereo
facile perché i bambini crescono e
vedono le leggono le fiabe e ovviamente
tu sei una principessa stai lì spett il
bacio tutto il resto o sei un principe
allora arrivi col tuo cavallo oppure o
sei una mamma metà delle famiglie
italiane non hanno lavapiatti no quindi
sei una mamma che magari di lava tre
volte al giorno i piatti in casa o se un
papa che esce e porta a casa quanto
guadagnato per la famiglia
questi sono gli stereotipi che sono
ovunque prendete i libri di testo delle
scuole elementari e spesso trovate che
ci sono donne che lavano piatti e uomini
che tornano dalla caccia questa questa è
l'idea che è che restano i bambini
questo è il primo gruppo di stereotipi
secondo gruppo di stereotipi abbiamo un
mostro invece che potremmo chiamare
frankenstein che era un po l'idea di
avere paura del cambio della tecnologia
questi stereotipi sono quelli del mondo
della scuola del mondo della
dell'università del mondo delle
opportunità del lavoro e questi
stereotipi su che cosa lavorano lavorano
sulla stima delle ragazze spesso le
ragazze viene detto che sono meno
portati in una cosa che sono un po meno
bravi in questo maxi carine non chiedere
troppo lascia stare ma qua c'è uno
stereotipo oggi che mi sta
particolarmente a cuore che quello sulle
materie scientifiche le cosiddette stan
siete mai chiesti perché in italia le
ragazze non studiano sono meno bravi in
matematica perché crescono con questa
idea perché sin da quando sono piccoli
viene detto o morto non si è portata per
la matematica tu fai un'altra cosa
o quando c'è il momento di fare la
competizione di matematica viene mandato
il compagno di scuola il maschietto ma
questa cosa qua si trasforma nei numeri
questa cosa qua è assolutamente il
risultato finale della nostra società le
bambine cinesi non sono così e non penso
che abbiamo un cervello diverso
semplicemente alle bambine cinesi non
viene detto che non sono bravi in
matematica quindi il punto dello
stereotipo sulle materie scientifiche e
un punto che oggi sta toccando
tantissimo la nostra società perché noi
abbiamo un bisogno estremo
di donne che si laureano in materie
scientifiche ingegneria che si lavano in
informatica che possano portare valore e
che questo valore lo portino come lo
portino con la loro diversità ma queste
ragazze hanno una barriera e la barriera
e molto prima e loro auto realizzano
appunto quella profezia un'altra cosa
stupidissima il mondo dei videogiochi
perché le bambine non approcciano
informate che il mondo dei videogiochi o
mondo fatto da maschi per maschi molto
molto più difficile se sei una ragazza
appassionarti ed entrarci terzo
stereotipo terzo terza porta sempre
nella nostra città immaginaria e che
abbiamo abbiamo king kong perché abbiamo
detto che lavoriamo sull'idea di
leadership quindi abbiamo lui e lei e
come sono e come sono come come ce le
immaginiamo ci immaginiamo sempre una
donna tendenzialmente che deve essere
educata di licata gentile capace di
prendersi cura
non vorrei fare il capo magari puoi fare
la numero 2 che così ti occupi un po del
team e poi ci serve ci serve qualcuno
veramente capace non possiamo avere una
persona vulnerabile
non possiamo pensare che uno nella vita
abbia pianto una volta e poi voglia fare
il capo o non possiamo pensare che tu
non sei disponibile 24 ore al giorno 7
giorni su 7 perché ai bambini ti devi
gioco pari quale quello ti chiede la tua
società
ecco questo è l'idea di che cosa ci si
aspetta da un leader
qui non voglio entrare in un tema di
genere voglio entrare in qualcosa di
nuovo e vecchio ci abbiamo bisogno di
una leadership diversa abbiamo bisogno
di leader vulnerabili abbiamo di bisogno
di leader che sanno ascoltare abbiamo
bisogno di leader che sanno dopo aver
chiesto prendere le risposte
rielaborarle e restituirle e anche
questo stereotipo non ci aiuta ecco
diciamo che abbiamo una fortuna che
tutti i mostri sono tendenzialmente
abbastanza vecchi tendenzialmente
abbastanza grossi affaticati abbiamo
detto che c'è il sole che c'è poca acqua
che fa veramente veramente caldo e
quindi abbiamo la fortuna che questi
stereotipi
questi mostri che rappresentano gli
stereotipi sono affaticati vivo in una
società in cui sono stati smascherati e
sono affaticate quindi ne abbiamo la
fortuna che forse si appisolano più
facilmente di altri e come e come
entriamo in queste porte come entrano le
donne in queste porte come facciamo che
voi uomini facciate entrare le donne che
più amate le vostre figlie le vostre
mogli e le vostre compagne le vostre
sorelle da queste porte che sono porte
che quando le donne a seri ci arrivano
sono sempre più strette per loro ecco
dobbiamo lavorare con le chiavi per
aprire questi stereotipi le chiavi sono
per il primo stereotipo il primo mostro
quello sotto il letto sono nelle nostre
case
dobbiamo cambiare dobbiamo cambiare il
modello culturale dobbiamo insegnare che
se abbiamo finito di cenare non è la
figlia femmina che sparecchia mentre il
maschio va a giocare alla playstation
non può funzionare perché abbiamo
tendiamo a scontrarci contro due
stereotipi
dobbiamo insegnare loro che tutti hanno
valori tutti hanno le stesse opportunità
e questa parte qua deve venire dalle
nostre case deve essere qualcosa che si
può respirare in casa con riferimento a
tutto lo stereotipo delle materie
scientifiche
date fiducia le ragazze fate sentire
loro che sono bravi e possono essere
bravi come gli altri perché è così
perché in realtà stiamo dividendo il
mondo tra ragazza che fanno materie
intellettuale più i ragazzi che non
leggono e che si sviluppano diventa
bravissimi informatica ma questo che noi
vogliamo o vogliamo dare a tutti la
possibilità di seguire quello che gli
piace di essere quello che sono più
bravi a fare e di seguire le proprie
passioni e di restituire il meglio e poi
abbiamo il il tetto stereotipo quello
della leadership ecco questa è la parte
secondo me più importante per persone
con intorno a questa sala oggi c'è
dobbiamo pensare a che cosa possiamo
fare oggi immediatamente per impattare e
in ogni posto s'impatta avendo le
persone più giuste ecco questo è il mio
sogno per oggi a voi che vi ho portato
sulla collina vorrei lasciarvi ii e
vorrei chiedervi una cosa se domani
mattina vi alzate provate a sognare un
mondo un po più variopinto grazie
[Applauso]